hello and ping and welcome to this video
I mean use my voice said much today yet
sorry yeah so back on track to play a
little bit of blitz iam on the chest
after a bit of a break a little bit more
than two weeks yeah I couldn't really
focus on doing any videos first of all I
was away for roughly one week to do a
bit of coaching work for the junior team
here of my state in Germany we had a
state championship and I was away and
really basically no chance to do
anything there and after I returned I
was very busy finishing my latest
chasuble project and there will be
definitely more information about that
soon there's still some things to yeah
to settle that same and then I will tell
you more what it is and when it will be
released and so on but I absolutely had
to finish the writing so that all the
next steps can take place and I was
basically working 24/7 I was thinking to
make a video but I was saying okay I
don't have the focus you know I'm one of
those people I can only do one thing and
then focus on it and if I am playing a
game and I know I should write or I
should do other things with the project
I'm simply not focused okay let's get
going here with this game against
Levesque the risk okay he per person
repurposed night to f8 yeah yeah okay I
mean I can take and he basically has to
take with the night
and then night will not come to evade
still I'm not going to have the simple
Queen d3 attacking mechanism in play but
this looks good right go to f5 and maybe
open up the Queen I can actually paint
and I have played some games on the
chess but I'm still not I'm still not in
that painting mindset let's say ok so
Queen age 5 there is g6 I can't jump to
f5 that is always going to be dangerous
I just don't know how much simply taking
is possible it's not a bad choice
yeah don't quite know what's best yeah
should unpainted yeah Knight f5 probably
bishop f8 and I'm not sure I have such a
great continuation I'm don't really mind
so much if he takes it
it's tough to say I have to really get
back into the flow of a blitz game I
haven't played any blitz game really for
two weeks not even at this junior
competition sometimes you get to play
blitz when you in add those those events
when you are not really working to
prepare the kids but when I had even the
slightest bit of time there I was
writing so there was absolutely no chess
playing for me okay so what is he going
to play here do you fought naughty for
something like that I wouldn't mind that
if that should be good for white no I
don't know if it really wants to take
but it's a reasonable pre move maybe d3
that could be interesting do you three
intending to play Knight to d4
yeah that's indeed what he does one
night to F warm
yeah maybe Queen f3 a 94 doesn't work
but she can maybe take play D 2 that is
in fact quite annoying 94 is annoying
anyway okay I have to decide on the move
maybe Knight f4 whom probably Queen f3
is a good reply I mean he cannot move
the knight anywhere as f7 hangs maybe 92
is a move but not really I think I can
just take it or I actually just move the
King yeah I can just move the King if
I'm I don't want to take and I can just
move it f7 is just hanging and my next
move was rook a to d1 if black goes rook
evade which looks kind of normal
okay here I can take p3 I don't see why
not
I could've taken d5 Knight f6 I was but
it was stupid I mean my position is good
yeah but but I had a had a clean window
yeah that was too quick we can take a
one-take t6 blundering this back that's
not good it's not good
I should've happened to read him Quincey
three for a double attack I can so take
it there's no maid
there's just not a maid yeah that that's
really not good
I came through have been over
yeah I guess he will trade yeah I got
rooked g7 but he's got Roop c7 that
which is a pretty good reply maybe this
is still posing a problem I don't know
with f5 coming let's go okay I know we
have six not quite clear to me if that
helps
could be bad from a structural point of
view but it made him think at least okay
keeping this phone I was going Knight g4
maybe maybe have to rock the rock move
group the one that could have been
tricky there should be four runs into
rookie forecheck
I think I think I missed some stuff here
my king position is slightly tricky for
sure
and now it's night has news that must be
fine right let's push the b-pawn know
it's there stalemate no King g8 now I
think I think I have blundered into some
some made maybe a that was a bit shaky
when he had the night down g4 yeah okay
let's have a look there I mean I
basically did not do any commentary on
the opening because I was talking about
what happened in the last days yeah this
looks pretty nice and I've got a good
space advantage and pawn on d5 is kind
of irritating black and now I'm I think
what I did is I think it's one of the
top choices probably it should look look
look fine
there should be three okay well but that
cannot be bad right I mean you cannot
look for perfection anyway in in a blitz
game that doesn't work so I decided to
take and play before I'm not sure that
this and this is best and it seems it
isn't Bishop III is good okay so Knight
is six I mean I'm actually worse yeah
uh-huh because of d4
I didn't take that into account William
Jim yeah I cannot really go hear him I
mean I can't do it but I think he just
takes and then who should takes here
right yeah that's also what the engine
gives something like that leads nowhere
I mean I don't have a problem but it's
it's not great here here maybe here I
can do things with the Queenie a Quincy
phone yeah I don't know that that is not
really convincing of course so I miss
played it here but he went back to his
six
and when a three rook c8 hey I hear
Queen dr3 was certainly possible okay
that that also made some sense to me
right before and now the engine wants to
play Bishop to g5 okay that does sound
that looks okay I'm if I could if Black
gets a queen on to d5 that is a good
position for him okay he went d3 ship
here my life form and Queen f3 Quincy
flawless even stronger Queen f3 the
check and in fact I can take yeah
you know I saw that but I felt he has no
good move here and it would have really
paid off if I just paid a bit of
attention because I simply can't take
and win the Queen so that is the moment
where the game should have been over of
course he does not have to take on d5
but I mean yeah and piece up a threaten
everything yeah it would be end of game
and now I'm better but it's not a win
and he I should avoid 96 that was just a
premature decision
something simple Queen here yeah and now
96 I guess it's probably just killing
black tea I just blundered the pawn back
and here it is nothing special I felt
maybe I can do something here with the
bishop the the knight currently it's a
little bit wrong footage if black had a
better square for this he would even be
better for sure I tried really hard here
I'm not sure if it is a great concept
here with f5 rook g8 or the coup reply
didn't see that at all cook see one
night here and then f6
yeah that is of course I'm boxing the
King end but on the other hand this is a
fairly fairly weak instruction if we get
rooks traded for example and black
manages to activate the King I will be
worse but with all the pieces on and
probably not
still I feel like I made maybe I did
something wrong here so here if he plays
rook t1 I have a g4 I know I'm
checkmating okay I cannot do that here
but the check came here probably there
never was anything I'm always
threatening made myself here rook e8 and
g4 and now by now I'm winning so h6 was
stronger it looks a little bit dangerous
all that rooks is 7 or g4 I probably
would have played G for him similar to
the game rule him but there is nothing
okay I wasn't entirely sure I felt like
I'm not doing it in the best possible
way like here 8 and the check and
blunder of this bag but but now I have
those two points I'm probably probably
winning you to the pawns and yeah it
should be ok I'm doing a little bit of
back and forth but once the the knight
is in that dominated position you should
be 5 against the knight is just totally
over yeah so some some moments in this
game it not really surprised I'm having
not played any blitz for two weeks
thanks a lot for watching